killed it so you know he's super a less
actor now he just did that Ferdinand
moving him I'm he's on fire aye-aye-aye
last time I saw him at the show I just
pulled him over for a second I just cuz
I don't really know him that well but I
wanted to know I wanted him to know that
I was so proud of him
not for what he's done as an actor even
though I'm super proud of him on that
level but how he carried the company on
his back for over a decade and still did
so much work for charity man it was
mind-boggling like no one has done more
along that whole make-a-wish thing than
Cena has but when I saw did you see him
when he hosted the ESPYs no dude you're
a comedian you know how hard that [ __ ]
is he is not extend up comedian but he
was friggin amazing well he's been
acting for so long now he's so loose and
you know this thing about being behind
the mic on the WWE as well I'm just
being able to do that in front of all
those people have a swarm absolutely I'd
say that's its own level of like
sometime 20 minute promos are doing the
rock confuses me in like how much energy
yes I don't know how the [ __ ] he can do
all the things he does yeah he's always
doing something like I go to his
Instagram page all the time yeah I deal
like a lazy [ __ ] he flies into China
it's 4:00 in the morning he's lifting
weights like what the [ __ ] man the
hardest-working cat I have never seen is
always doing something yeah I mean he's
just sandwiches everything together I
don't know how the [ __ ] he does it yeah
I'll tell you Jericho is I put like guys
like who are the most insane workouts
like right now rock is way past
everybody he's past anyone I've ever
seen at me toe and and I'll just a
tional II put it you know just a tweet
out just says hey dude keep up the great
one of those guys where I go how long
did him human how long can the human
body like this cuz you know he's only
sleeping for hours at night he's gonna
yeah I think he's kind of like my buddy
Steve you they don't need to sleep they
just keep going Jericho's the same way
Jericho when he's not wrestling he's
singing when he's not doing that he's
doing his podcast so he's not doing that
he's doing this for he's doing that or
he's doing this or doing that and like
he flew in paid friggin private jet
him into the all-in deal and I didn't
even know I don't like to know I want to
be surprised and they shot this angle
with Kenny Omega who's one of the like
premier superstars in our business right
now and they did him in Jericho at 47
sold-out the Tokyo didn't known 47,000
people in January his match these
wrestle for the entrances everything
were 48 minutes they wrestled for 37
minutes he's 47 well he jumped on a
plane while he's touring they flew him
in he put a mask on you thought it was
one guy he pulls the mask off after he
drops Omega and bought a boom it's
Jericho the place goes batshit crazy he
gets out grabs his deal hops on a plane
and flies where he supposed to play at
12 o'clock that night
that's Jericho no and the other guys
Batista so Batista yo between galaxies
well I mean there's four guys that are
like red hot as actors and they're all
the boys he's fantastic and guardians of
the galaxy so good at being like
self-deprecating dorky I mean he plays
like a goof so well and he's such a cool
dude man he's only an scoffers here
right now he would be jizan and now